" Bonsoir. Merci d’être
en direct avec nous.
Cette soirée est une première
dans l’Histoire politique de ce pays
et c’est une première
pour la télévision."
La musique ça me replonge
dans cette espèce
de tension gigantesque.
Parce qu'évidemment, ça représentait
un évènement ultra important
dans la vie de LCP
et donc accessoirement
dans la mienne aussi.
Les débats présidentiels
à la télévision se résument
dans l’Histoire politique
de la Vème République
aux grands débats
de l’entre-deux-tours.
Il n’y a pas du tout cette culture
qui est plutôt une culture américaine
des débats pour les Primaires.
Je crois que c’est vraiment l’intuition
des 2 présidents de l’époque
d’avoir saisi et compris peut-être,
avant les autres chaînes
que cet évènement allait devenir
un évènement médiatico-politique
et tout simplement d’avoir
sauté les premiers en fait.
" - Laurent Fabius,
bonsoir!
- Bonsoir!
- Ségolène Royal,
bonsoir!
- Bonsoir!
- Dominique Strauss-Kahn,
bonsoir!
- Bonsoir! "
Arrive ce premier soir du débat
là toute la journée,
on avait senti la tension monter.
Je crois qu’il y avait eu
un papier dans Le Monde.
un papier dans Le Parisien.
Il n'y avait évidemment encore jamais
eu vraiment de papiers consacrés
à nous comme ça.
Et en fait c’est assez
tardivement je crois que
que j’ai pris conscience que...
Ah oui quand même!
" Alors ça ne vous a pas échappé,
le 16 ou le 23 novembre prochain,
l’un d’entre vous sera
le candidat du Parti Socialiste
à la Présidence de la République.
L’enjeu est donc de taille
pour vous ce soir.
Les Français vous regardent. "
On avait Jean-Pierre Elkabbach
et Richard Michel
tous les 2 dans l’oreillette.
Mais on a eu beaucoup plus
Jean-Pierre Elkabbach
qui n’a pas pu s’en empêcher.
Je pense qu’en fait il avait
envie d’être à notre place
donc il serait bien venu cuisiner
ces 3 éléphants socialistes.
" - Je vous ai parlé des délocalisations
Dominique Strauss-Kahn
mais vous m’en parlerez
peut-être plus tard?
- J’en parle très volontiers.
- Il vous reste 30 secondes pour
nous parler des 35h, Ségolène Royal,
sinon vous ne pourrez
pas en parler, c’est dommage.
- Je pense qu’il faut qu’on revienne
à ce qui a été dit au début et qui est juste…
- Merci. "
Je me souviens juste
qu’à un moment, il m’a dit:
«Arrêtez de sourire!»
Alors je ne saurais pas
faire la voix d’Elkabbach
«Vous souriez trop.
Vous avez un joli sourire,
mais n’en abusez pas».
Ça m’a évidemment plongée
dans un désarroi terrible
parce que je me disais:
bon qu’est-ce que ça veut dire?
Ça veut dire que j’ai l’air
d’une cruche à l’antenne?
En revanche, je pense que c’était
aussi une manière de contrôler mon émotion.
Sourire, ça peut être aussi
une façon de se donner une contenance.
C’est un nombre de téléspectateurs auquel
bien sûr à l’époque sur LCP
on n’est pas du tout habitués.
Mais ce qui est vraiment
intéressant
c’est que depuis c’est vraiment
devenu un genre télévisuel en soi.
On s’est tous habitués à voir
le débat des Primaires,
à gauche, à droite...
Mais il faut bien
mesurer qu’à l’époque
ce n’est pas un spectacle
politique
c’est un spectacle auquel
les Français ne sont pas du tout habitués.